[Music]
you hater despite all this [ __ ] in her
life
she's made something of herself and you
can't take it
because she's strong beautiful
and black
this is not a biopic on billie holiday
this is a moment in time of billie
holiday's life
and the government trying to take her
down
she keeps singing this strange fruit
song and it's causing a lot of people to
think the wrong things
taking her down because she was singing
a song
strange fruit which was about lynchings
black people being lynched when you
think of civil rights leaders you think
of martin luther king
you think of malcolm x you think of
gandhi but you don't think of a woman
billie holiday susan lori parks hands me
this incredible script
the story was so incredible that i
thought it was made up
a lot of us have you know heard about
billie holiday ashley was a great singer
we all know that
and yeah she had a drug problem the
billy holiday we don't know so much
and that's why it's important to tell
this story is that billie holiday was a
fierce
warrior sister right she was a fighter i
think we should integrate the audience
for the show
you know blacks and whites sitting
together i love billie holiday i
really really love her i have always
loved her and this idea that she gets
boiled down to just some
tragic troubled drug addict i love the
idea that she would not be seen as a
victim she'd be seen as the fighter that
she is
writing it on the page i wanted people
to know the other things about billie
holiday
and to connect the distress of her life
the distress
of the injustice of america so slp wrote
the scene
billy sees a lynching the emotional
intent
of doing these scenes in one shot was to
create
a real-time but out of body experience
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i got it ready come on come on
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
it was the hardest thing i'd ever done
the hardest thing i'd ever
shot because it wasn't just about the
actors being
in place but me
holding with andrew dunn who brilliantly
shot this for me
holding on billy throughout this entire
crazy she gets off the bus
unknowing she gets off the bus to
release herself to have a pee in the
bushes
as you hear some noises and goes off
through the bushes
and finds these distorted and
desperately
sad as their mother is hanging from the
tree
and the father is hanging on to the
mother now our
idea for this is to shoot real time and
to
make a continuous action
so we don't exactly know where we are or
when we're there
or if it's present or past or future
so the idea was to weave our way through
that scene
and use sound to to catapult us through
and to make us feel help us
feel what she's going through
[Music]
we wouldn't have a lot of room in that
cabin so this is another situation where
i had to
move a wall in as she would walk through
it
it was quite incredible really and it
really all culminated for me when we
actually
shot the scene you can hear the kids
crying and the father
trying to get the mother down and i mean
literally people were crying uh as we're
watching the
the monitors quite moving how horrible
must it have been to see
that and not just to see a lynching
but to know that that lynching was just
a casual day in someone's life
when lee put the scenes together made
them all one continuous scene
which is just a brilliant directing i
think as he strung those things together
he really
captured in the visual medium what i was
trying to do
thematically on the page my song
strange fruit
it reminds them that they're killing us
the similarities is that i am a black
woman i'm living in america in 2021 but
i'm still a black woman
there's a sense of almost invisibility
you have to shout so loud because you
know you're not being heard
i hope that the audience takes away from
this moment what it's like to see a real
lynching
and what it's like to really be on
heroin
a combination of both
[Music]
lee's expertise is to get inside of
billy's head and get inside her head
then bring the movie out from inside
that's one thing that lee is so great
the lynching itself should be enough
but we as a people are too familiar with
this
magnitude of trauma with this
level of loss while we wanted to
stay true to history and to billy's
story and to her legacy
we had to remind ourselves that we were
making art
she was truly the godmother of civil
rights she sang strange fruit alerted
the nation that black people were being
lynched
the maze of that to her
singing the song and we understand the
importance of the song
it hits you in a different way than
it has before strange fruits
the strange
fruit
blood on the leaves
and blood at the root
black bodies swinging
in the southern breeze
strange fruit hanging
[Music]
from the poplar trees